digital data is just basically ones and
zeros but they add up to so much more
they carry information about technology
negotiating strategies and company
secrets every day the computers of
German companies are attacked by spy
software that copies and steals their
data yeah kruger safari survey german
businesses and we've learned that in the
past two years one in four companies has
been affected by data theft and possible
spine but that's just those who noticed
it there are country specific risks and
companies felt threats from Russia China
Eastern Europe and the US I think that
speaks for itself take it a swish
position the United States spying on its
friends even if there's no conclusive
proof of that trust in that ally has
been seriously damaged making
appearances such as this one seemed
especially absurd at a security
conference Michael Daniel the
cybersecurity coordinator for the White
House called for closer cooperation
since the US and its allies had this
same goals after all the threats that we
face today maybe the threats that you
face tomorrow or in ten minutes teamwork
is a requirement and speeches back home
I often say cybersecurity is a team
sport but Germany and other European
countries don't want to cooperate as
before instead the debate over national
solutions has begun a recurring theme as
the stance that Germany has to do more
on its own without the u.s. different
think nuts we shouldn't isolate
ourselves but as long as other countries
don't have a certain level of data
protection we can't use their products
some regulation is important but we need
to convince others to adopt our high
data protection level we need to present
ourselves confidently we're a strong
economic nation so we have a certain
market and regulatory strength which we
need to put into use illegal young smart
in this bit or in small screen national
rules for the World Wide Web that sounds
pretty illusory as does the use of
domestically develop technology Germany
doesn't have much of
computer or software industry the most
important developments come out of the
US and the technology from the Far East
Europe is lagging behind technologically
and is only now starting to develop a
strategy for cybersecurity val- problem
list is a cybersecurity strategy is a
kind of wish list and there isn't really
an implementation strategy that we have
the problem that we don't have the
personnel and that there's no money
behind it we take a lot of care
regarding basic protection against
pickpocket seba but when it comes to
protecting our businesses against
industrial espionage and our sovereignty
against spies we're not really doing
anything protecting against spying
attacks from the internet is still new
territory for German security
authorities indeed they're still
generally more interested in gathering
data themselves than in preventing
others from doing the same the debate
reflects that focusing largely on
whether and for how long communications
data should be stored Thomas was a
terrorism and organized crime or threats
and we need data to prevent them but we
shouldn't go as far as the Americans but
we need a storage period limit that
exists in 27 of the 28 EU members and
Germany can't stay on the sidelines I'm
bandaged up such idiots i divided
building of a further database when
we're not even sure if the current ones
are protected is unacceptable we have to
reach a joint solution on a European
level one that maybe reconsider storage
period limits and the condition for
setting up such databases that I not
monroy nothing Germany's
telecommunications providers are also
taking a new approach by looking for
national solutions German data should
remain in Germany and not be routed
through other countries because after
all information is far more than just
ones and zeros
you